everyone being involved matters but if
the leadership is not on board and is
not
consistent about talking about it living
it
putting it into action it will not
happen in the organization
[Music]
celine williams welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
i am wonderful thank you how are you i i
am doing great thank you very much i'm
in tel aviv and where are you
right now i'm in toronto canada
in toronto canada and uh you know the
the one good thing that maybe happened
and through this whole crisis that i get
to talk to people from all over the
world in all sorts of weird hours
i'm watching darkness you're watching
the sunrise it's a it's beautiful
celine executive coach founder of
revisionary
vast experience both in the
entrepreneurial scene in the tech
ecosystem whether it's as a mentor
business development culture coach
you name it i'd love to talk about
leadership and about the different
challenges that people face and how to
overcome them
what we can learn from the pandemic and
what you've learned over the past 20
years as a coach
so why don't you start off by telling me
a little bit about yourself and we'll
get the ball rolling from there
sure so i'll tell you a little bit about
my journey uh because i i
as much as i would love to say i've been
a coach for 20 years since i came out of
university that's not true um but i have
had i've had a vast
career past career i've done a lot of
different things
um so i when i was actually in
university i started
my first business that i always joke was
like the result of greed
basically i saw i didn't want to be
making seven dollars an hour working in
like a retail store um so i started
tutoring for a company
uh which was you know i was making 25 an
hour which when
you know most people my age were making
seven i was like this is great i'm
rolling in money
and then i found out that they were
charging students 50 or 75
an hour wow and i was like hold on
no no no let me i'm just gonna do this
myself and so i started a tutor
like so i joke it was out of greed but
it was really
an opportunity that i saw that i had was
i
had a sort of a specialty in tutoring so
i was getting a very specific group of
kids that were coming to me
so i was like why don't i leverage that
and just do my own thing so that's what
i did so
um you were talking to me about making
an hour it's not about the greed it was
about the opportunity
and about the curiosity and continue
their journey from their place
yeah so i um so i started my business
and then i ended up
creating a program it was at the time
um i basically it's so funny because i
look back and
when i talk to entrepreneurs and what
i'm mentoring i often
use this story even though it was 20-ish
years ago because i created
a program with a very specific niche of
students in mind and a very specific
need
and i got you know i became known for
that program so when i
i moved to montreal i ended up taking a
corporate job which is
i'll get into in a second i sold the ip
for that program
because no one was doing it right it's
like listen it was a tutoring program
it's not like i was
making millions of dollars it was enough
but like i sold it to another tutoring
company because
i hadn't you know found a specific niche
created a
a solution for a problem that they have
that no one had thought to do so over
the next
few years this tutoring company used
that for the
for you know and brought those students
in there so
un subconsciously i guess unconsciously
i had done this thing that we talked
about with entrepreneurs all the time we
talk about when you're
running a startup when you're getting
into business i just kind of done it
accidentally and it worked so
i i did that um during one of the
summers
before i moved to montreal probably two
summers before i moved to montreal
um i had a friend reach out and say
hey do you want a three month contract
at this company in healthcare
that had just gotten a whole bunch of
funding from health canada because it's
socialized health like we have universal
health care here the government gave
this
company tons of money it was this branch
between
it was in health informatics so between
tech and health care
and i was like i've me 23 24 years old
whatever it was was like i've never
worked in an office that sounds
great so i took a three-month contract
that lasted 11 years uh so i wow
there for 11 years i did a whole i did a
number of different things i worked in
hr for a bit
um i worked in change a lot of the stuff
i did was people focused right change
management
i did stakeholder engagement
communications i just kind of
moved every couple of years to new areas
like
i got a promotion and moved to a
different area which was great
for what i do now because i got to touch
a lot of the people sides of the
business
you know less on the tech side although
i did project management which was the
fun
back and forth between tech and business
but i didn't actually do any of the tech
side but i got to
be in that world um
so as somebody that's coming from the
tech side and knows practically nothing
about the hr side tell me a little bit
about that
oh well uh um
i what i thought hr was was not what my
hr experience
was which is really interesting in the
work that i do now so
what i i was like really low level when
i was doing hr it was like hr
coordinator stuff very general
lots of stuff on benefits like all the
like very
um transactional side of hr is what i
was doing
and the company i worked for truth be
told as much as their hr partner wanted
to be a partner
they were very transactional it was not
about culture
it was not really about people it was
about like
you know sign the contract get the
contract done here's your benefits
here's what
make sure everyone has pencils it was
that kind of thing
so i did not it was i did not like it
because i
you know the thing that i think is great
about hr
is and i want to acknowledge this i
fully recognize that benefits and
compensation and things like that are an
integral part of hr i
i 100 that matters
however if hr is really about
humans if it's really about people if
it's really about
creating a system that supports and
empowers and enables them
then it has to be about culture and it
has to be about leadership
and it has to recognize those things and
startups are so much better at doing
that than sort of more traditional
companies are
and this was a company that was startup
was more of a startup before got the
funding and then got really bureaucratic
so it very quickly got out of that and i
was like this is not
this is not fun it's just paper pushing
is that part of what then
led to your curiosity and passion in
regards to
cultural building and leadership yeah
it's a hundred percent
when i left that when i left the company
i'd already done
training to to be an executive you know
executive and business coach
i very specifically done the training we
went through a program
um focused on that as opposed to
something like life coaching because i
it's that was not me but sort of
executive business coaching was
definitely
up my alley and in starting to work in
that area and looking for clients
i started naturally i don't know if
that's the right word for it but
i started attracting startups in toronto
in the ecosystem i you know won an
entrepreneur award ended up in a
co-working space that had a lot of
startups ended up working with a bunch
of them i just kind of naturally it
started happening
and culture was a thing that i had been
talking about because my experience of
culture had been so crap
so i was more talking about it from uh
don't do these things
right right like you can do culture
intentionally
culture by design you can do culture by
design
here's some ideas i have of what that
looks like here's some ideas of ways you
can make that real
and they started hiring me to actually
implement it and actually work with them
at designing it
and so it was funny because this thing
that i was passionate about because i
had such a terrible experience
and with the note that i could it took
me years
inside of corporate to figure out what i
didn't like because i liked
a lot of the people that were on my team
i was really lucky i had incredible
leaders
incredible leaders that i worked
directly for and wonderful teams that i
worked on
however i hated the experience of the
company i hated the experience of
all of these other things and it was a
culture thing because they that
they didn't really care they you know
they'd say one thing do another thing
the leadership was
was out there talking about something
and then doing something totally else
you know totally different inside the
organization they'd
change the you know my favorite example
is they
were talking about changing the mission
something like that mission vision of
the company they want to update it
so they got everyone in the company into
workshops
to give their opinion and the the
statement that they went with
was the statement they came in starting
with because they'd already made the
decision they didn't actually care
that's a terrible way to develop culture
because what you've said is we think you
care about being involved
but we don't care about your opinion
right so
after experiencing things i was
literally just talking about don't do
these things
and here's 25 examples of things not to
do that destroy your culture
once i became aware of the concept wow
and so slowly before we continue because
as i as a young entrepreneur myself that
i'm very excited to dive into my own
venture
sooner rather than later a lot of my
friends listening to this are you know
in their early stage startups
what are some critical things that we
should not do as we're building culture
whether it's intentionally or
unintentionally what are some really
like
don'ts so i think you know
oh my gosh it sounds it's gonna sound so
basic
but don't say you're going to do
something or don't say things are a
certain way and then
people have a different experience of it
um
i think that it's really easy to say
here's what here's what the if you're
doing it intentionally it's really easy
i'm going to talk about that and i'll do
unintentional
a second right so by design if you're if
you're a company you're starting a
business and you're saying
here's what matters to us and here's
what we stand for
and here's what our values are and
here's what you know whatever
whatever that version of it is for you
and those are all wonderful things to do
however if the people in your company i
don't care if there are five of them or
500 of them
if that is not their actual lived
experience
you are undermining the culture you are
trying to build so
you cannot say it is one way and then ha
not have it be that way
i work with large organizations right
now on making sure
that if they're saying this is their
these are their values this is their the
vision that they live by this is how
they show up
at making sure and going through and
that that is the
experience of the vast majority of
people and
if it's one person's not experienced
in a large company if that's not their
experience because they don't want
it to be that's very different than this
entire team is not operating in that way
right so making sure that that is
aligned is really important
transparency i'm guessing a classic
classic example of that would be for
example many companies today
love saying that they support a
bottom-up innovation approach
right the the top people at the pyramid
would love that the bottom
level layers bubble up these ideas and
there's gonna be
people that listen to them and they're
gonna get hurt and then sometimes when
when you know push comes to shove you
have an idea you go to the p
to your boss and you get the door in
your face because it's not
it's not the kpi that you were tasked to
solve by the end of the quarter
so speak to me in christmas right so and
that obviously something that could very
easily undermine a culture and an
organization
absolutely that's a great example of it
another one that i hear a lot
is organizations say that they are um
that feedback matters to them right like
whatever their version of
we care about feedback we give feedback
all around
you know we believe in continuous
improvement feedback is a key you know
agile organizations often talk about
feedback is really important
and when you go to give feedback people
don't listen to it people ignore it
people have don't have the tools to
receive it
they you they get defensive whatever
that undermines
when that becomes systemic one person
doing it
fine that person you can they can get
coached through how to
get better at receiving feedback there's
lots of alternatives but
when it becomes systemic you are
undermining the culture that you are
purporting
to to to be creating and so that
consistency i would actually even use
the term consistency might be a better
term than what i used before
but consistency inside of how what
you're saying and then what you're doing
is probably the most toxic
starting point for what undermines
cultures
as they are as you are designing them
and i would
and i would say that when culture is not
your if you're not doing culture by
design you're allowing it to happen by
default
it's a little bit different because if
you're not saying here's what we care
about as
for our culture here's what our we care
about for leadership
and it's kind of a free-for-all the the
the problem there becomes there's no
everyone is doing their own
thing and you get siloed right you get
silos inside the inside the organization
and this happens in you know companies
of 35
people it does not have to be a large
organization to have
communication that is siloed and the
minute communication is
siloed your culture cannot thrive it
cannot because you're not sharing
information
people don't know what's happening they
only care about themselves
it becomes you know it's less of a first
team mentality and more of a
like protective not sharing in from so
it's different but it's just as toxic
what what has been incredibly successful
in building culture intentionally
first and foremost hands down it's
getting all the leaders on the same page
it is if you have one leader who cares
about culture and everyone else is just
kind of going along for it because they
have to
or going along with it going along for
it going along with it because they have
to
nothing's going to happen it's not going
to change it might while you're working
with someone or while it's
the conversation topic people might be
like yeah let's do this thing
but it doesn't it doesn't filter down it
doesn't trickle down it doesn't get to
the people that
are going to be implementing it every
day so i
when i started talking about call and i
want to be really transparent about this
when i started talking about culture
i was like yeah you need the leadership
on board
but it's not the only thing i have many
more years of experience now in this and
i
100 percent say this yes
everyone being involved matters but if
the leadership is not on board and is
not consensual consistent
about talking about it living it putting
it into action
it will not happen in the organization
it will not
so the most important thing is that the
leadership is actually on the same
page and committed to the same things
when it comes to culture and it comes to
leadership
and when that happens
truly and i've worked with incredible
organizations where
you know a new ceo came in or a new you
know for whatever reason
their lens on culture was different they
made the effort
to change the conversation at their
direct table level their leadership
level
and within a year the culture in an
organization
had transformed wow
and we're talk i'm talking like large
organizations
so it's possible even if it wasn't a
conversation before
and i and i want to acknowledge that
because it's never too late to start
this conversation as my point it's never
too late to start caring about culture
but it definitely the the leadership
table
has to be committed to it and care about
it
and this is what's so nice about
startups is that
often the people at the executive table
at the leadership table
are younger and care about it more
because they're not used to the way
things were done 20 years ago
so it's a great opportunity to really
really change the conversation and get
people on board it's so much easier
than someone who's been an executive for
40 years who's like well
i've always done it this way i'm going
to keep doing it this way so much easier
to do it with startups
wow so what do you get most excited
about when you are working
as a coach today
what do i get most excited about um
i man i
am really lucky to get to do what i do
and and you know i want to start i sound
so cheesy but really i'm really lucky i
um i love watching people
have a realization have a shift in their
perspective like my company's tagline
and shift your perspective because
that's the thing that
you know the people i work with always
say they're like i every time i talk to
you i get a shift in perspective
you show me a different way of thinking
about things
and it's not about me being right and
saying this is the way to do it it's
just
that little shift becomes a shift in
behavior becomes a shift in something
else and so i love those moments
where people have that shift and i think
the
the one of the biggest one of the things
i'm most excited about when i get to
work
with people is is shifting them
i'm going to use the word shift 800
times apparently but shifting them out
of black and white thinking
into gray thinking if you will but
i love that so much
thank you and and really so much of how
we think about things becomes black or
white
you know i don't care if you are this is
your first company you've ever founded
it's in its first year
you're brand new to to to building this
business you're learning
i guarantee you you are operating
90 of the time from black and white
thinking
and if you've been doing it for 40 years
you're operating 95 percent of the time
from black and white thinking because
our brain loves certainty
so we create these structures and
you know based on i was raised in a very
unique way
by very unique parents under very unique
circumstances
and i tend not to do
a lot of black and white thinking
naturally less than most people just
because of the nature of how i was
raised
and i have all the training now and i've
done so much work in it that it's
really i'm very quick to be like
or we could think about and people are
always like that's the
like just that that just that helps a
ton
and i and you know i think those are i
think those are things
i love watching people have that
realization that
that thing that they thought was real
and
right and true was just a construct
in their brain and they get to change it
if they want to
celine it's inspiring i i love that
thinking
i i'm an optimist by nature and i
remember as a team leader in various
organizations
and more on the tech side the thing i
hated most was when somebody came to me
and said michael we have a problem
i always ask them to transition to
michael we have an opportunity for a
solution they hated my guts for doing
that
it annoyed the hell out of them but but
at the end it worked because
that whole shift and mindset and
understanding that that not
nothing is black and white there's
always a scale and you can always
tilt the scale and you'll you'll never
get exactly what you want but it's
somewhere there
celine thank you for being so generous
with your time before we leave i have to
ask you the most difficult
and important question which is three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
the first one i i always use is curious
um
because i annoyingly ask one million
questions all the time
so so i would say curious is definitely
one of them
um i would say
i'm very earnest so
um i don't love the word authentic all
the time but i'm very earnest i
believe in people i believe in the you
know being who i am
and kind of showing up that way also
probably annoyingly for people in my
life
uh but you know it is what it is um
and i would say that
um i i think i would say
courageous i would say courageous one of
my values is courage
um and i tend to
take things on with no evidence that
they're necessarily gonna work
and face things as they come
you know from a place of optimism much
like you right where it's like i
i really trust that things are gonna
work out and so i just step into it and
i have a lot of courage in the face of
of the unknown
um so i think i would fulfill your
prophecy right thank you very much
selene thank you very much stay safe and
stay healthy
and continue helping people become
better leaders thank you very much
thank you michael it was lovely to chat
with you i appreciate it